thank you I see a lot of you here today
I'm surprised because I thought you were
all going to be drunk and in bed this
morning but very nice to see a girl
young minds so as Kenny said I'm going
to or Harris said I'm going to speak
about immigration and I don't know how
many of you heard this story about you
know FDR that he was speaking one time
before this group called the daughters
of American Revolution which is a
lineage based outfit like so you have to
be connected with somebody who was
present at the time of the Revolution to
be a member of this organization and he
greeted them all by saying my fellow
immigrants and actually as it turns out
the story is completely false he never
said that and which is a good thing for
me because I can use this greeting now
at this gathering and not be accused of
quoting FDR and defending and defending
any libertarian and I guess there are a
couple of you in this room here today so
my fellow immigrants there is actually
no issue that I write about in as Harris
said I write about a whole number host
of issues there is no issue I write
about that generates quite as much hot
passion as immigration does I mean it is
the most controversial issue of the day
and the interesting thing about my
readers is that you know and the
restriction is readers from whom I get a
lot of hate mail it is that they don't
actually fall along you know racial
ethnic lines so they are not all you
know white anglo-saxon Protestant males
they actually are pretty racially
diverse so you know I have they
represent sort of this cross-section of
American society and there are Jews
Catholics Chinese Indians I mean I get
hate mail from every possible ethnic
group and what's true of my readers is
actually quite true of the pundits and
the advocates of the more restriction is
position so if you you know think about
it the Center for Immigration Studies
which is the key restriction is outfit
that advocates a total moratorium on all
in
raishin legal an illegal it's run by an
Armenian American and you have Ramesh
Ponnuru who writes for National Review
which is a long-standing history of
opposing girl you know more relaxed
liberal immigration policies and he's an
Indian American and then you have
Michelle Malkin who's a Filipino descent
and you know she can trot out
anti-immigration tropes with the best of
them and you know so it is not an issue
which actually is driven by racism in my
view it is there's something else going
on over here and I think you know the
people it what's interesting is that all
these people were immigrants and they
come over here and they immediately want
to pull the drawbridge to the next batch
of immigrants there is I think
anti-immigration sentiment sort of
appeals to a certain tribalism in us you
know once we become members of the club
of United States of America we don't
want to dilute you know that membership
by just allowing anybody to come to the
country and so there is I think
something like that which is driving
this sentiment but that aside I mean I'm
not here to psychologize my opponents
I'm here to actually make a libertarian
case for immigration or more open
immigration and so far you know the most
the mainstream Pro immigration case that
you hear falls along two lines there's
the conservative case for immigration
and then there's a liberal case for
immigration and the Conservatives who
defend immigration they do so on
economic grounds it's good for our
economy and liberals who defend
immigration they defend it on
humanitarian grounds you know we've got
to do this it's you know we have to help
out the world but for libertarians the
fundamental reason to support open
borders is that it's the only position
that's consistent with limited
government you know that's the case we
are interested in hearing and we want
and both negative a negative Liberty
that minimizes government intrusion in
our lives as well as positive Liberty in
the sense of pursuing our own happiness
you know sort of the Jeffersonians sense
and I mean positive Liberty here I don't
mean positive rights and so don't don't
in the question-and-answer session
asked me if I you know want to get
immigrants over here because we should
be sped spreading our wealth around
that's not my point so I'm going to make
a few quick observations about the
conservative the economic case for
liberty and the humanitarian the liberal
case for liberty and then I'll make the
libertarian case for liberty point out
you know what some of the shortcomings
are in these positions so you know if
you consider the economic case for
liberty I mean we hear horror stories
about how Americans American workers are
constantly losing their jobs to low wage
immigrants that these immigrants depress
American wages and you know what have
you and the interesting thing here is
that they're economists whose work
opponents of open borders like the sight
as a Cuban American you know there goes
again - you know immigrants themselves
are opposed to immigration and his name
is George Boras how many of you have
heard of him okay yeah so George Bohr
has who is a Harvard economist smart guy
he is the one who's been making a most
important economic case against
immigration but even Boris admits that
immigrants make a seven billion dollar
net contribution now this is you know to
the economy
this is far lower than what you know
most economists put it at it's close to
25 billion according to most economists
but you know all of that aside I mean
you know we don't need to be you know
you can debate what the precise
contribution is of immigrants to the
economy but you can't doubt that they in
fact do make a contribution to the
economy because insofar as immigrants
have jobs it is because they are
producing more value for their employers
than they are then they are consuming in
wages and benefits it's only when they
produce value are they going to get jobs
and so the fact that they have jobs
should tell us that you know they are
they are beneficial and they are more
beneficial to the employer than the
alternatives for the employer so if the
employer were to hire native bonds or to
get some machine to do that job that
would be less advantageous for the
employer than hiding this immigrant
that's why
this immigrant has a job and so whatever
the dislocations and the hardships that
immigration might cause to specific
groups of Americans on the whole for the
economy it produces net benefits and in
this sense you know immigration is like
trade there are some losers specific
losers but on the whole you know most
people are better off but there is one
objection to these comments that people
make and it should be addressed which is
that you know this would be true that
immigrants are producing net value for
the economy if we didn't have a welfare
state but when you have a welfare state
essentially what you're doing is you're
privatizing the benefits of immigration
for the employers to the employers but
you're socializing the costs because
employers don't have to pay immigrants
everything you know that the immigrants
need because they're connecting you know
various welfare services and so
therefore the taxpayers are picking up
the cost of immigrants now this is I
mean this is not an argument that we
should simply dismiss it's a serious
argument but the fact of the matter is
that every empirical study that has been
done on this question has found out that
a in America the welfare state is simply
not big enough as it is in Europe to be
a major draw for immigrants and this was
true even before the 1996 immigration
reform bill which actually after that
immigration reform bill was passed
immigrants were denied their you know
now all kinds of mean tested benefits
they are not eligible for so they are
not eligible for food stamps and on
illegible for all kinds of health care
and what-have-you but even before this
welfare law was passed Julian Simon had
and how many of you are familiar with
Julian Simon yeah he had done actually
one of the most definitive studies on
immigration and welfare and he had found
that on balance immigrants consumed less
in welfare than native-born populations
and they produce far more in benefits
than they consumed in welfare but you
know even if the welfare state were to
become a draw for immigrants what the
what would the answer be the answer
would be to get rid of the welfare state
right I mean not get rid of immigration
but that's not an argument you hear very
much and in fact is there anybody
the Cato Institute over here no okay
well then good I can beat up on the Cato
Institute so you know even the Cato
Institute I mean their position is
immigration yes
welfare no and as you know on the
surface it sort of makes sense but I
actually don't support that position and
if any of you are interested you can ask
me in the Q&A why I think that's not a
good position do you have so but quite
apart from the benefits to the American
economy what I've labeled sort of the
conservative economic argument for
immigration there is also a strong there
are also strong humanitarian arguments
for immigration the liberal argument and
if you think of the you know if you
think of the two major you know the word
foreign policy and our aid to foreign
countries both of those are driven by
humanitarian concerns to a very great
extent and both of those would be better
served just if we open the borders and
had a more open immigration policies so
if you think about it
you know the liberating the oppressed
has been at least part of the rationale
behind nearly every major war of the
last hundred years world war two you
know that was one reason a Korea Vietnam
Balkans Iraq all of these wars one of
the arguments that the you know defense
establishment was making was that those
awful tyrants are doing awful things to
their people and you gotta do something
about it now in Iraq of course you know
we heard this argument a lot that you
know we were went in there because we
wanted to remove the boot of Saddam
Hussein from the neck of his people that
was one of the core justifications of
the war and so in this war US has lost
4,000 of its soldiers and it has spent
hundreds of billions of dollars you know
in fighting this war but if liberating
people from Styron II was such an
important goal of the Iraq war then
instead of sending American soldiers and
guns to Iraq we should have just been
giving visas to Iraqis to come over here
right I mean you liberate them very
quickly you do that I mean that's what
happened in East Germany for example you
know we had been fighting the cold war
for a long time but then what actually
ended the communist dictatorship the
Berlin Wall came down the East Germans
they
mass migration to West Germany and
suddenly the whole communist apparatus
you know their star ze and there you
know entire police state kind of crumble
because it didn't have any victims left
you know to tyrannize and so giving
people an exit option is sort of the you
know the best the cheapest way to be
humanitarian but you know they're quite
remarkably you know how after the Iraq
war started and you know they were in
Rockies who were helping coalition
forces you know telling them who the bad
guys were and what have you and they
were facing persecution in Iraq you know
that they were the Sunnis who were going
after the Shiites Shiites going after
the Sunnis for collaborating with the
United States and these people wanted to
flee somewhere they wanted the to 2
million of them actually fled Iraq and
you know how many the Bush
administration took in any wild guesses
here no they took it 500 in the first
four years of the war they gave you know
asylum to 500 people and after a great
deal of international outrage and
pressure they increase that number to
the grand total of 7,000 so that's about
how many you know Iraqis we have taken
in so it's kind of it's just kind of
boggles the mind
but just as American guns are not the
most effective way of helping people
living under tyranny American aid is not
the most effective way of helping people
living under poverty so every year the
United State gives about twenty eight
billion dollars in aid to foreign
countries and we know what happens to
that aid it goes you know into the
pockets of their kleptocratic rulers
very very little of it actually reaches
its intended audience by contrast if you
had a generous work visa program in the
United States it would cost the US
government nothing it would actually
produce economic produce economic
benefits for us and it would you know
help the poor people in third world
countries and my formal reason colleague
Kerry Howley actually she wrote a very
good column one time and she kind of
summed this point up beautifully and
this is what she said she said there is
no development policy no feasible amount
of foreign aid no poundage of fair trade
coffee that will help someone
developing country to do to a better
life than opening the door to a better
economy instantly doubling or tripling
the value of their labor
that's essentially you know what you do
they cross the border and the same you
know labor the price of it goes up three
or four times so immigration in fact is
the best anti-poverty program and and it
doesn't again cost us anything so those
are all you know pretty good arguments
that open immigration policies
simultaneously improve the American
economy improve the lives of the world's
you know poor and destitute those
huddled masses that the Statue of
Liberty refers to but from the
standpoint of libertarians what's most
important is that only such policies are
consistent with limited government open
immigration policies are not ultimately
about helping immigrants but protecting
the rights and liberties of Americans
themselves and I think this point has
been emphasized nearly not enough in
this immigration debate and I think that
is actually you know one of the reasons
why we are at a political stalemate you
know we just haven't seen any movement
in opening up our immigration policies
now liberal advocates of immigration
make it sound like open immigration is
all about the rights of immigrants and
that makes it very easy for
conservatives to sort of portray them as
you know Pro immigration bleeding hard
you know sort of advocates you know who
just want to spread America's largest
around and so you ran that doesn't see
both sides are kind of stuck over here
now if the you know the I think a
consistently libertarian position that
shows that you know open borders is
about protecting the rights of Americans
themselves you know it's a very powerful
moral argument I mean this is you know
one of those political opportunities
where I think you know libertarians can
seize the moral high ground and you know
appear like children's of Salomon you
know like we are these wise people and
yuba knighted conservatives and liberals
fighting at each other on the wrong
terms and we can sort of reestablish the
terms of the debate over here so but
what is the kind of case that we would
have to make I mean as well sort of lay
out an argument that we could
politically to sort of change the terms
of the debate the first is a very
Hayekian argument you know Hayek argued
very powerfully that when government
interferes with the peaceful voluntary
activity of individuals to achieve some
collectivist end and it doesn't matter
whether that end is you know a
conservative end like protecting you
know preserving your culture or whether
it is a liberal end like more equality
that you know when you pursue
collectivist ends you inevitably you
know unleash unintended unintended
consequences and the government when the
government fails to achieve its ends
this has not been perceived as evidence
that there is something wrong in these
ends themselves it is always seen as
that we didn't use sufficient force to
you know achieve these ends and these
efforts are redoubled and then you're on
your way you know to the Road to Serfdom
and this is the logic that has played
out in the war on drugs for instance the
ban on drugs is not stopping people from
Brian buying drugs it has just spawned
an illegal trade in drugs this is the
logic by the way that has also played
out on the war on high-flow toilets I
don't know how many of you are aware of
this but in Michigan some years ago the
government actually banned high flow
toilets because they used up too much
water and so what did Michigan citizens
do they would cross go across the border
to Canada they would buy that high flow
toilets they would sneak them under the
noses you know of the customs officials
didn't produce a stink and they would
have their high flow toilets so there
was a smuggling ring in High Flow
toilets in Michigan for a long time and
this is kind of the logic that is
playing out right now on immigration you
know we are militarizing the the
southern border it's like we built a you
know we're building a Berlin wall on the
Rio Grande and it's all a wall because
we want to prevent willing employers
from hiring willing workers so so that's
a pretty good Hayekian argument against
you know restricted borders but you know
what would but then we also have to go
further and we have to lay out what
would a Princip
libertarian immigration policy look like
in a world of nation states where
borders are not going to be scrapped any
time soon and we can't just simply throw
open the borders and say everybody and
it's politically just not going to go
anywhere so I think what we have just
but what we can realistically strive for
is building a presumption for liberty in
our immigration laws and that's I think
where we have to go with this so what do
I mean by this so right now the best way
to think about American immigration
policy is that Americans have to justify
to their government why they want to
bring someone to the country and I think
it should be the other way around I
think the government should have to
justify to us you know why we shouldn't
be allowed to bring somebody to the
country either because they pose a
public health threat or they pose a
security threat or what have you and if
the government can't make that case to
us then we should be able to bring
anybody into the country you know and we
shouldn't have to explain ourselves to
the government this was by this is not
as wacky as it sounds because this was
actually the u.s. immigration policy
till you know 1930 there were we had
virtually open borders people would just
show up on Ellis Island and if they were
sound of health and didn't have a
criminal background they would be issued
a visa right there and they would be in
they would be actually employers
standing in line to hire these guys when
they got off the ship so it was a very
efficient program that's not how things
work anymore the way to think about our
immigration policy is now there is a
blanket ban on immigration and then the
government creates various categories
allowing us to you know relaxing the ban
in these specific categories that it has
created and so I'll go over some of
these categories to just show to you how
crazy this system is if you think about
it rationally consider the category of
asylum for instance and Asylum applies
to people you know who are trying to
flee persecution now actually the it's
very strange but only the government can
grant asylum so you know if you have a
friend or a relative who's stuck in Iraq
and Saddam Hussein wants to kill him you
can sponsor this person to bring them to
the United
States so it and if you try to help this
person you know flee the flee Iraq and
come to the United States you can
actually be prosecuted yourself so this
is like think about the how bizarre this
whole thing is that American government
can send you forcibly to Iraq to keep
liberate people in Iraq but if you want
to bring somebody of your own free will
well then you're going to be arrested
that's how you know crazy or asylum laws
are but take another category of family
based immigration the government bars
Americans from sponsoring family members
unless they are blood blood relatives or
spouses the spouses must be of the
opposite sex gay partners need not apply
even among blood relatives the US
government decides who gets priority and
who doesn't so minor children it's
fairly easy but if you have a child
who's over 21 years old then it's very
difficult if you have cousins who want
to come that's out of the question
and if you want to you know invite a
close friend to come and live with you
over here that's just not even in their
category so you know so that's not just
not possible and so essentially these
immigration policies are not violating
the rights of immigrants as much as they
are violating the rights of Americans
who want to bring people over here for
whatever reason this becomes even
clearer if you consider employment-based
immigration I mean most Americans don't
quite relate to family based immigration
because you know they don't have enough
people outside the country whom they
want to bring in but employment
employment-based immigration affects
everybody the government gaps the number
of high-skilled work we visas you know
that it issues every year to 85,000
before the recession this was about half
of what you know various companies
needed and this the this visa the
application for this visa would be
opened on April first and it would be
filled within two days the cap would be
reached and then the companies that
would have to wait for another year
before they go to plot I mean this is
you know and this is for high-skilled
immigration for low-skilled immigration
you know construction companies or
housecleaning or landscaping companies
or farmers or
have you you know who are employing
unskilled workers there are no literally
no categories available for them to
bring in workers so there is no surprise
that you know you have so many employers
who are just breaking the law and hiring
people illegally and so whose rights are
our immigration policies violating its
the rights of our employers right but
instead of and you know here then you
see how the Road to Serfdom logic is
playing out in all of these categories
so instead of relaxing America's
immigration laws in the face of this
widespread non-compliance that you have
in certain sectors of the economy the
government is actually like redoubling
its efforts to stop them from hiring
these workers so one of the you know
programs that has been enacted now and
this is the latest buzzword in
immigration circles now is a restriction
a circles now is interior enforcement
and interior enforcement essentially
what that means is that we are going to
make the life of illegal immigrants over
here so miserable and the people who
hire them you know so difficult that
these people will leave voluntarily on
their own that we won't even the
government won't even have to take you
know draconian deportation measures
these people will just leave on their
own and so in order to do that the
government has put in place something
called the e-verify program which means
which will require employers every time
they hire anybody to check this person's
eligibility for work in a federal
database and if they can't find this
person in the federal database well then
they are not eligible to work now you
can't have a specific program just for
immigrants every Americans name will be
in this database so essentially what the
government is asking is that every
American has to get a permission slip
for work before they can get employed
because their employers have to verify
whether or not you you know you are
immigrant immigrant or non-immigrant and
if you are immigrant whether you are
allowed to work but Congress is actually
not the only entity you know which is
sort of getting into the this business
of making the life of immigrants and
their employers you know
miserable you've all heard of the
Arizona law how many of you heard of the
Arizona law okay good so a fair amount
number of you
so essentially what the Arizona gained a
lot of notoriety last year when it
passed this law which will authorize you
know police and other law you know
enforcement officials to just stop
anybody on you know who looks suspicious
to them and ask them to produce their
immigration papers to prove their legal
residency now you know they say they are
only going to you know go after people
who pose a reasonable suspicion but who
poses a reasonable suspicion anybody you
know who's brown skinned as an it and
has an accent so it's not just
immigrants there are you know I'm a US
citizen and I have brown skin and I have
an accent if I were in Arizona I could
be stopped you know and asked to produce
my papers now this is a kind of you know
your papers please policy when do you
know when we saw this Nazi Germany I
mean I mean I hate to use you know make
comparisons with you know Nazi Germany
but you know that's where this law was
you know most consistently applied and
so so you
I mean so you see Hayek's argument and
work over here his logic in work over
here you start with wanting to restrict
immigrants immigration for just
immigrants and you end up swallowing the
whole Bill of Rights so I think these
you know these are the kinds of
arguments I think would have a great
deal of cachet with the American public
if we if we've made them that we are all
going to be collateral damage in this
war on illegal immigrants that the US
government has decided to launch the
before I go on to the next part I just
want to actually take up this one
objection to my argument that Lib that
libertarians actually make and one of
these libertarians is this guy Gahan's
Herman hopper guys heard of him yeah
hopper okay
the journals of libertarian studies in
2007 had actually done like a whole
issue on open borders and immigration
and hapa had come out on the other side
on the restriction aside and he actually
made some pretty ingenious arguments so
this is what
Hopper's argument was he said that in a
free if in a free society if people you
know he agrees they ought to be left
alone to associate with whoever they
choose and not a source associated with
it with whom they don't choose but
that's not possible in a quasi socialist
country such as ours because the
government owns roads parks utilities
taxpayers have no way of denying access
to those whom they find objectionable so
furthermore anti-discrimination laws
that I government put in place after the
civil Civil Rights Act force private
establishments such as restaurants to
admit people against their will and
employers to hire people they don't want
to hire and even worse public schools
and a rampant welfare state forces
taxpayers to subsidize habits and
lifestyles that they might find
objectionable and so he says under these
circumstances if you allow open
immigration what you're essentially
doing is you're coercing integration so
open immigration leads to coerced
integration and that he thinks is you
know not very libertarian so so is that
a good argument I actually don't think
so and I would be interested in hearing
your thoughts you know in the Q&A now
the quarrel that libertarians like hapa
have against you know for this forced
integration argument that they make is I
think ultimately it's not against
immigration you know it is an argument
against any changes in population or
demographics so what do I mean by this
essentially every argument that they
make against immigration can also be
made against children child birth as it
were is the primary form of immigration
right that's how children you know
that's how we gain access to a whole new
group of people and we can confidently
predict that many children born today
will grow up to be objectionable adults
and some of you are here I know they
will be objectionable adults who many
taxpayers will subsidize against their
will and better judgment all these
children will use public roads and a
vast majority of them will go to public
schools and some of them will also wind
up on welfare a fume
become criminals or even worse they
might vote for Democrats and if they are
members of certain minorities they will
benefit from affirmative action programs
and forced hiring laws right yet nobody
would argue that empowering the
government to restrict child birth
especially of inner-city minorities is
an advance in Liberty right I mean but
that's essentially what happen is
arguing so if that is the case if you
know not for if if we are not going to
prevent inner-city minorities from high
rate from having children by what logic
can we prevent say a Chinese citizen
from getting five family members from
China I mean there's the arguments is
essentially the same but why the block
who is a professor at Loyola University
he actually has another very good
argument to reject the you know the
habían position and this is what his
argument is he says it is undeniable
that in our current system you know
opening the borders will force some pack
taxpayers to pay for immigrants they
don't want but by the same token closing
the borders will force other taxpayers
to finance - finance measures to
restrict entry of people whom they don't
want to bring in right I mean so there
is a rights violation either way so
given that perfect justice is not
possible in the system of you know this
cause I'd mix system that we have the
issue from a libertarian standpoint
become becomes which of these two
policies is going to lend itself to
expanding you know to expanding the
scope and power of government the least
so you know do we you know move towards
a limited government position if we
close the borders or open the borders
and those who doubt that an open border
policy is best on this count or to
consider this a state that is powerful
enough to prevent people from coming in
is also powerful enough to prevent
people from going out and there is such
a state that exists which has you know
this perfect control of its borders and
it is called North Korea and North Korea
is the ultimate serfdom right so I don't
think the happy end position there for
you know
itself two more Liberty on its own terms
so now I was just in conclusion so my I
had promised you that I was going to
make not just the negative case for
liberty but also make an affirmative a
positive case for liberty
and this case rests on this you know the
Jeffersonian promise that we all have a
right to pursue our happiness in this
positive sense that we you know need to
be able to maximize our opportunities
pursue them as we see fit America is a
nation of immigrants and it's built by
immigrants but actually in no time in
this country's history has open
immigration been more important than
today that's because you know in a
globalized world Americans opportunities
are going to lie less within their own
borders and more outside the borders you
know America's vast size has kind of
historically offered Americans plenty of
opportunities at home you know to find
jobs open companies marry whoever they
want to and you know what have you and
so America's exploration missions unlike
those in Europe have been to outer space
you know Vasco da Gama and Christopher
Columbus you know they they scope the
world to look for opportunities outside
their own borders but the American
continent is so huge that we never
really had to do that until now now in a
globalized world you know companies
American companies are establishing
offices elsewhere they have you know and
they want to put Americans in other
countries so as Americans you know
expand out of America they are going to
meet other people you know they are
going to form strong bonds your
generation is going to be a predict
forming strong bonds with people you
know outside their country occasionally
you know you'll form friendships you'll
fall in love you know you like the food
of people outside this country you will
want to bring their chefs over here to
open restaurants with them none of that
is going to be possible if we have the
kind of immigration system you know that
we have right now so in short you know
in this world of extended horizons you
will find that the people who best meet
your needs for work enter
and love live not next door or in the
next city or in the next state but in
different countries and if you let an
acoustic immigration policy stand in
your way
this will fundamentally compromise
Jefferson's promise to create an America
where you can pursue your own happiness
as you see fit and there is something
you know really wrong with that so you
guys should not put up with it that's
why
you